Here are the answers, and great thinking if you got all three correct. For the
first one, we want to multiply by the square root of 2 divided by the square
root of 2. We really multiply by a form of 1 so that way we can change our
denominator to the square root of 2 squared. This allows us to take the square
root, so we get 2 in our denominator. And this is what we mean when we
rationalize a denominator. We multiply our fraction by a form of 1, so that way
our radical does not appear here. For the second one, we want to get rid of the
square root of y in this denominator. So we multiply the numerator and
denominator by the square root of y. This gives us the root of xy here, and the
root of y squared here. Our factor of y appears twice inside of our square
root, so the root undoes our power and we're left with y. Notice, another
fraction with no radical in the denominator. That's rationalizing. And finally,
for this last one, we just want to multiply the numerator and denominator by
the square root of 2xy. Now you might be wondering, how did I get this. Well
there's an intermediate simplification step. In the numerator, we'll have 4
times the root of 2xy. In our denominator, we know if we multiply the same
square roots together, we'll just get the radicand, which is just 2xy. Now we
simply 4 divided by 2 to get 2 divided by 1. Here's our final result.